their corporation exists only as
cover for their wicked means to live or
rather
to remain undead
i tell you now saburo is not gone from
our world
he rests undisturbed in the family crypt
he feasts on the blood of his servants
away
so saburo is definitely dead like
trust me on this such conviction
you witnessed his death with your own
eyes
well just so happens i uh
no i did not die you see
you see
but how could mere mortals become these
death defying
with the help of techno necromancers
from alpha centauri
it was their tainted blood saburo
arasaka drank to transform himself
into this devil's spawn gary you can't
spill arasaka's secrets
they gonna find you let them the seed
has been so
the truth shall sprout roots and lift us
from the invaders clutches
i recognize you you come here often
your eyes tell me that your mind has
opened to the truth
will you provide a humble donation so
that i may continue my mission
humble sounds affordable just don't
spend it on stupid [ __ ]
thank you this has bought me a day or
two
if you turn a blind eye to their
existence they have already won
radio waves bear the truth let those
with ears listen
and those with eyes behold
their mothership conceals itself above
our very heads
ready yourself for they are coming
open your mind before it is too late
if you turn a blind eye to their
existence they have already won
the truth
open your mind
[Music]